it's uncomfortable being around strong
seals great seals they're always raising
standards most people believe it or not
don't even like working with great seals
because it's not comfortable it's always
raising standards it's almost a feeling
of it's not enough it's not enough I
mean I thought we're doing it's not
enough we're not there yet we're not
there it's always a standard next every
time I feel like I get someone you move
the marker that's the job of a leader
every time I feel like you go through
you're moving a little bit more man why
when are you gonna be fully happy yes
that's that's what makes them so special
that's why history books is gonna favor
Bob in motion when he dies a bunch of
people going by his book cuz they want
to know what made him so special to save
AIG from a major you know debacle or
major issue that they were gonna be
facing right because they know how to
raise everyone's standards I remember
we're in Napa Valley and Bob memo she
walks in when there's a meeting going on
everybody in that room that reported to
him was uncomfortable it's so funny just
watching everybody they were
uncomfortable because he's a leader he
raised the standards